this strategy sets out our three-year  plan to improve the health and  well-being of residents in castle point  and the rocha district it outlines the  work that we will do and the key areas  we will focus on as well as the  principles and approach we intend to  take we are working together at a  grassroots level to make the biggest  difference in our communities  this strategy has been co-produced by  board members and builds on learning  taken from the last strategy  since september 2020 we've been coming  together in small subgroups to develop  the narrative and thinking behind our  priorities  we have shared knowledge insights and  case studies from our local residents to  ensure their lived experience is  reflected in the strategy